LYNN HIRSCHBERG: So
I thought that we
would start by talking
about this day,
and how you got involved with
global climate and things
having to do with the
International Day of Happiness.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Well,
there's so many parts of it.
I got invited back in
'07, 7/7/07 by the way,
by Al Gore and Kevin Wall,
to be a part of Live Earth.
Which was this movement, and
is this movement, about climate
change, the effects
of global warming,
another issue--
people's denial of it.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Big time.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: And I
found myself just really
being concerned.
And once you realize the
gravity of the situation,
I found myself being
really concerned.
And so we put on this concert.
And we had different people
and different kinds of--
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
This was back in '07?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yes, in '07.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Wow.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: And we
sang for climate change.
And this time we're
doing it, we'd
like to have a billion
signatures or more.
Because there's seven
billion people on the planet.
And we have the reach now.
So for me, I think
my contribution to it
is just-- I was the creative
director the first time.
They're making me creative
director the second time.
I just want music.
And I just want to
literally have harmony.
I want humanity to harmonize.
I was going to say
it differently,
but it wasn't coming out right.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
And that's going
to take place-- today is the
day you're announcing that.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yes.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: I see.
And were you familiar with
International Happiness Day?
Was this something
you knew about
before you wrote the song?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
I didn't know.
No.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Because I
never heard about it until this.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: I didn't
know for a short while either.
And then it was like,
yeah, there's a day.
And actually, one of our
buddies from Virgin-- excuse me.
Did I really do that?
I'll tell you why I said Virgin.
It's because a lot of the crew
that are at Columbia Records
now are from the original
crew of Virgin Records.
And so one of the guys there
had a really good idea,
when speaking to
the UN, of this idea
of merging the two intentions
together-- the intention
of the song "Happy" and the
intention of the International
Day of Happiness.
And somehow we ended up
here in this great place.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Exactly.
Well, let's talk a little
bit about the song "Happy."
One of the things that interests
me about the song "Happy"
is that not only does it say
happy, but it sounds happy.
Was that your intention
when you wrote it,
to make a song that
actually elicits happiness?
When you put that
song on, I don't
care if you've heard it two
million times, you feel happy.
As opposed to just
the word happy.
Because other songs could say
love, you don't feel love.
So there's this amazing
synergy of the lyric,
the music, the whole
feel of the event of it.
I will confide that my dog
even responds to the song.
He starts wagging his tail
every time it comes on.
He just gets happy.
Was that part of what you had
in mind when you created it?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: No.
[LAUGHTER]
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: I thought
I was on to something,
but apparently not.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
OK, well yes and no.
Yes in the sense
that I was trying
to meet the expectations
of the director.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: This was
created for the animated movie.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yeah,
for "Despicable Me."
In the script and
the actual moments,
I was trying to
connect that emotion.
But I did not know that it
was going to turn into this.
I did not know that I would
be here today doing this.
I did not know that when you
look at the views collectively,
what those numbers look like.
I never realized
ever, or dreamt ever,
that a song could do this.
And part of watching
it happen is
when you realize it's not you.
It's the people.
I'm sure you guys have
heard me say this before.
But it's the countless numbers.
It's the numbers of the people.
It's their activity that turned
that song into what it is.
It's actually their song now.
They sang it more than I did.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: I think
it's all of your song.
But that was interesting, too.
Because the initial idea
for the video incorporated
all these people.
Was that in your
head at the time,
that the song would have that
kind of unifying approach?
Or did that just
come about because it
was cool to have all these
different people sing the song?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
We didn't know.
We didn't know that that
was going to happen.
And when it did, it just
kind of like caught fire.
And we were just like, whoa.
Because that's when
you realize it just
has nothing to do
with you anymore.
I'm telling you, that's
the most humbling thing.
Something that you do,
when you're no longer even
a part of it anymore
and it just goes on
and takes on a life of its own.
There's no greater version of
being humble to me than that.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: But
what's cool is also
what Google has done
with this Happiness
Project, the Happy
Planet Project,
is basically make
it even bigger.
So they're
incorporating both what
you're talking about with
global warming, and the song.
It's taking on different
ramifications all the time,
which is kind of amazing.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yeah, again,
I can't believe I'm here.
But it's awesome.
And Live Earth is something
that we want everyone
to participate in.
It's really honestly
like a global party.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
But tell the story,
because I think it's so
interesting and actually
kind of educational, and
makes me always feel better,
about how long it took
for "Happy" to catch on.
How the song was out--
anyway, you tell the story.
Because the genesis of the
song is so interesting,
because the success of
it would indicate that it
was successful from the jump.
And that's not what happened.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: No.
The movie came out in July.
And we went to radio with it.
And it didn't sound
like anything else
that was going on.
It wasn't the trap song.
[LAUGHTER] And it
wasn't an EDM record.
There was no
[SOUND OF HEAVY BASS BEAT]
[SOUND OF ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
You know, it wasn't that.
They were like,
what is this record?
What are you doing?
I was just excited that
we were able to pull off
those kind of chord
progressions and something that
had to do with pop culture.
So when it didn't go to
radio, it was like, oh yeah,
I didn't think it
was going to happen.
But look, me and my wife, we're
going to go to the movies,
and we're going to watch it.
And this is actually
going to be in there.
And that's enough for us.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
That's so nice of you.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
That was enough.
I remember us both tearing
up at the premiere.
And we were good.
We were like, OK, cool.
Done.
And six months went by.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Six months.
I think everyone
who does something
should think about that.
No matter how
great something is,
sometimes it doesn't
hit right away.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: And we were
like, we have to do a video.
We have to.
Karen who runs i am OTHER,
was like, we have to.
We can't let this record go.
We love it.
And I was like,
yeah, I do love it.
Because it felt good to us.
Remember, we didn't think
it would have this effect.
We just knew what
we felt internally.
So we were like, let's just
take advantage of the moment
and just do it anyway.
And then so Mimi
Valdes said, well
if you want this to
be considered and get
that kind of light, you
should do exactly what
Gru was doing in the video.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Gru being the
character in "Despicable Me."
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yes.
I'm sorry.
See, that's why we have
the professional here.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Just
for those of you who
don't go to "Despicable Me."
Which is no one in
this room, of course.
Everyone's seen it.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: We shoot
the video I think in November,
toward the end of November.
I want to say like the week
of the 20th of November.
We put it out.
And it just exploded, the video.
It just exploded.
And we were like,
are you seeing this?
Is something wrong?
And then you go look
at the iTunes page
and you just see
all the countries.
And I'm just like, what is that?
And from my perspective,
I'm a producer.
So I'm definitely not expecting
anything like this to happen.
And the look on
my face right now
is kind of like the way I felt.
And I still feel that way.
I really do.
What that song did is that song
made me change my perspective.
And now I feel like I make
music because it feels good.
And that's the only
thing I want to do now.
If it doesn't feel good, I don't
want anything to do with it.
And it's not because I'm
trying to ever feel this again.
Because "Happy"
is its own thing.
But I just want to continue to
just explore different feelings
and thoughts.
And I want them to
be vivid like that.
And the song, after it
was done, showed me that.
I didn't go into it
with that intention.
Nor did I set out
to tell people that.
But it told me that.
So then that made me change.
And it made me say to myself,
OK, now you can't go back.
You know what this
feels like now.
And not being the face of the
song, or singing the song.
I'm saying, you know that
a song can feel this way.
You can't.
It has to be this way.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Did you
ever hear again from radio?
Do you remember the first
time you heard them playing it
in heavy rotation on the radio?
Because I felt
like that was so--
I love when a song feels
like it's everywhere.
And that song just
was everywhere.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
Well, the beauty in that
is that for a moment, radio
became like this monster
that people felt like they
had to conquer in order
to be a part of.
And I have to say, it was the
DJs and the program directors,
that when the song
actually did start working,
they would tell us, man, you
know what, we tried it at first
and it didn't work.
But we're so happy for you.
It does work.
Man, you should see
when it does this.
My daughter, my son,
my di da di da di.
And if it weren't
for the radio DJs,
if it weren't for the
program directors,
and when they did get behind
it, they went full throttle.
And I have to say,
if any of you guys
are listening in radio right
now, and program directors,
thank you.
You have changed my life.
You have changed my perspective.
And I would argue and dare to
say that you've essentially
changed the world.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: I would agree.
And here here.
It's a good thing.
[APPLAUSE] Today on the
radio when I came here,
the UN Secretary General, Ban
Ki-moon, he was praising you.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
He talked about it?
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: He
talked about you.
And he talked about this day.
[LAUGHTER] It was on the BBC.
You can look it up.
It was on BBC
Radio this morning.
And I felt like, wow.
I'm going, it's exciting.
And he said that when
he is blue, to be happy,
he listens to music.
And he said that the
thing he listens to most
is-- he said, of
course, "Happy."
But he also said, I'm an old man
and I listen to Stevie Wonder.
So the question
is, in your life,
what music has made you happy?
At different times in your
life, have you turned to music
to change your mood?
Or was there any particular
thing that just made your day
when you heard it?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
How serendipitous.
It is Stevie Wonder.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Really?
Which particular-- "Songs
in the Key of Life"?
Any particular song?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
There's so many.
There's so many albums.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: You've got
to pick a song, like "Happy."
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: A song?
It was tough to do that
when talking to him.
We did the special.
And also on Snoop's album, there
is a song with Stevie Wonder,
myself, and Snoop called
"California Roll."
You guys have to check it out.
Because he's on there singing
and playing the harmonica,
and it's just unbelievable.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: You can
do it when you were young,
like when you were a kid.
When something would
come on the radio,
what got you in the
mood, in a good mood.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: OK.
Now, this is going to
sound very confusing.
But when I was young,
I didn't really
know what all my emotions were.
And I didn't realize that the
songs were making me emotional.
I just realized that there
was a difference whenever
certain songs came on, and
chord changes would come.
Different patterns would make
me feel a certain kind of way.
And it would mostly happen
in Stevie Wonder songs.
Or Earth Wind and Fire songs.
It's those jazz progressions,
they mean everything.
They just, they lift you.
Ask Elton John, he knows.
Chords do things.
Chords are actually coordinates.
Because they take you
to a different place.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
But it's interesting
that you talk about chords.
Because you started
out as a drummer.
So you would think your
thing would be rhythm.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
It is at the core.
But I think what really just
makes me move is chords.
I don't know why.
Chords and a melody is
just kind of like, oof.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: That's
why "Happy" works.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Man,
I'm just glad that it did.
Because the thing is,
I was lucky enough
at the time to have CeeLo
on the song with me.
And he sounded so amazing.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: I never
even knew he was on the song.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yeah.
CeeLo Green was on
there with me at first.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: He's
in the movie version?
There are two versions, right?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: No, he's
actually on another song
that they elected
for him to be on.
But he was on there
with me originally.
And I have to tell you guys, he
sang it way better than I did.
That's why-- I've even
brought it up, I was lucky.
I'm like, man, if y'all
woulda heard CeeLo's version.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: But you still
have to give me a Stevie Wonder
song.
Just give me one.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: I
tried to get out of it.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Just pick one.
"Signed, Sealed, Delivered"?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
Yeah, I mean, there's
"Signed, Sealed, Delivered,"
there's "Blame It on the Sun,"
there's "April Showers,"
"Don't Worry 'Bout a Thing,"
"Do I Do," "All I Do."
He's done it all.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: When you
meet somebody like him,
do you get nervous?
Or is it just like you have
that common language of music?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: I'm
too busy paying them
compliments and taking notes.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: I see.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yes.
Because when you're
around masters,
like the abbot that
Stevie Wonder is,
when you're around
someone like that,
you listen to his
every utterance.
Because you're lucky
to get that time.
That guy has moved mountains.
"I Just Called to
Say I Love You."
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Now
that's a good one.
I think everyone loves--
see, everyone went awww.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Or "You
Are the Sunshine of My Life."
He's done this.
He's done "Happy"
20 billion times.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Not really.
I mean, he has.
But the thing about
"Happy"-- he's
done it in a different way.
Those songs have a
different-- I think
because it's a different time.
"Happy" has a certain
cohesive thing.
It brings people together
in a different way.
I think that was a different
time, when there were
more songs on the radio and
things felt less-- "Happy"
feels very special in that way.
It feels very-- even when you
do like five seconds of it
on "The Voice," I get happy.
When that girl-- in case
you guys didn't see it,
there was one of the
girls auditioning
who was in high school.
She didn't make the show.
But Pharrell sang
"Happy" with her.
And it was an incredible moment.
You sort of changed that
girl's life in a second.
It was great.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
Well, she changed mine.
It made me get up.
It was one of those things,
it's like, it's in the room.
That's the thing.
If we could just continue to
surrender to the things that
just feel just and
right, like what
you've got to do at that
moment, it'll be a better place.
But that's what today is about.
Today is about everyone
taking on the idea
that happiness is a
birthright to everyone.
And so is freedom, by the way.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: OK.
So that brings up
my next question.
You have, correct me on the
word, synesthesia, right?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: A
lot of musicians do.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
Is there a color
that you saw when
you did "Happy"?
You guys know what
synesthesia is, yes?
Explain synesthesia to them.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: OK.
Here we go.
All neuroscientists,
forgive me ahead of time
if I start to use words
that don't really fit.
I'll start speaking
metaphorical.
Which is a side
effect of synesthesia.
So, synesthesia
is when your mind
sends ghost images to
other sensory departments
of the brain.
So if you hear something,
because, in a sense-- OK,
don't hold me to this, because
this is the world watching.
But in a sense, it's like
all of your nerve endings,
when you're born, they're
supposed to prune.
And some of them stay connected.
And so if your sight
and your hearing
are connected, then
if one sees something,
then it sends a ghost
image to the other one.
So if I'm hearing
something in my mind
where the perception is,
my mind is telling me
that I'm seeing colors as well.
But there's all
kinds of synesthesia.
There are people who
actually taste colors.
Or are there are
people who see sounds,
or people who can taste
feelings or smell a feeling.
Or they smell a color.
Like they smell purple and
it doesn't smell grape.
It's pretty weird.
A lot of artists have it.
A lot of writers have it.
A lot of artists have it,
just across the board.
From fashion to architecture,
they will tell you.
And it's no coincidence that
the blues is called the blues.
Or bluegrass, there's definitely
colors associated with music.
And the ROYGBIV, ironically,
just so your know,
it matches the keys,
the Western keys,
that we recognize--
the 12 notes.
Those controversial things.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: So
when you were young,
did this freak you out
that you saw colors?
Or did you just get into it?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: I thought
everyone was like that.
And a lot of people are, though.
It's not rare.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: So
"Happy," what color?
Yellow, I guess.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yellow.
There's orange, and
there's like red.
Those fiery colors.
And I think it's
because of the nature
of like the jazzy, bluesy
colors in the chords--
chords in the chorus colors.
And in the verses, it's major.
So it's very church, and kind of
does that to you a little bit.
Did I just describe that
in front of everybody?
And poorly, by the way.
But that's why I see the
yellow and the orange and red.
But they made "Happy" yellow,
obviously, behind the minions.
And it fit perfectly.
It feels bright.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: So
here's a question
I asked you before that
you had a great answer to.
What are your five favorite
non-musical sounds?
Sounds that are not made
by a musical instrument.
You don't remember
what you said?
You can give me one,
just give me one.
Because I don't want
to pressure you.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: I'm
so afraid of what I said.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: You
said great things.
You said great things.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: OK.
Ask the question one more time.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Five-- one
favorite non-musical sound.
Like champagne corks
popping, or a dog sighing,
or waves, or traffic, or--
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
My son's voice.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: There you go.
A lot of people say
their son laughing.
Does your son have a good laugh?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: He does.
He does.
And the things that he
laughs at are so wrong.
We have that in common.
Like father, like son.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: He'll
just start cracking up.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
Oh man, he falls out.
And sometimes you have to,
Rocket, that's not funny.
You're not supposed
to-- that's not right.
Just when we get home.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Does he
do a version of "Happy"?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: He
doesn't in front of me.
It's really interesting, my son.
Like he watches so intently.
And then you see it
coming out of him later.
But it's never a thing.
He's just now saying
sometimes, Dad, I
want to go to the
studio with you.
He's just now saying that.
Other times he comes
in and he's just
like, I want to go to the booth.
I don't want to do your song.
I want to do my song.
OK, not that.
Let me do this.
And then he's in the booth
for like 20 or 30 minutes.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
Does he have a song?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
Oh, he has several.
And I'm proud of him.
It's been amazing
to see the stuff
that he comes up with
at his young age.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
That's so great.
How old is he?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: He's six.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Wow.
That's a great age.
OK, so what's the rest
of your year look like?
I imagine you have
a long, big plan.
Do you have a new record?
I say record, because I'm old.
Do you have a new album?
Do you have a new, whatever, CD?
What do we call it now?
Do you have new music?
I don't have a computer even.
I'm old school.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
I'm in the kitchen.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
You're in the kitchen.
But you're a busy man.
You have "The Voice,"
and the kitchen,
and the saving the world thing.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Musically.
Musically, I'm in the kitchen.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: And
what does that mean?
Although it sounds
very exciting.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
It means I'm trying
to be poker-faced about it.
But I'm so excited.
I really am.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
Do you get, I mean,
do you feel pressure because
of the enormous success
in the last couple of years?
Does that make it
more difficult,
or does that not
affect you at all?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: No.
You only feel that
kind of pressure
when you think you did it.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Interesting.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: When
you realize that you
don't have that control.
And the only thing
you can do is just
make what feels
good to you, then
you let go and let God,
and let the people.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: So,
how is "The Voice"?
What is it like
being on "The Voice"?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
It's an honor.
You meet all these
incredible spirits.
You meet these people who
have the craziest stories.
Take a kid like Sawyer.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: He's amazing.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: He's 15.
He's never heard
of Robert Johnson.
He sings the blues.
He sings CCR.
He's from upstate New York.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: A farm.
He grew up on a farm.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: I
mean, it's just crazy.
Or Mia Z. These are
15, and 16, and 17.
This girl, Corinne,
17 years old.
Beautiful, but when
she sings, you just
hear the grounding of the Earth.
And I was like, how do you?
When I was 15, I would
be so embarrassed
for you to read those lyrics.
Or hear anything that I
was doing at that time.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: You
were probably great
when you were 15.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Oh man,
but these kids are superior.
They're superior to
what we were doing.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: Is that what
surprised you about the show?
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Because you-- first of all,
I've never been in a room
or in a situation with
that big of a concentration
of that much talent in one
room and under one roof.
And then, because there's
so much talent there--
like the scouts
there are genius.
But because there's
so much talent there,
you realize two things.
Some people have it in
them and they sing amazing.
And some people sing amazing,
but they don't really
know where they want to go.
But what you guys are
seeing on TV is you
guys are seeing
people show themselves
and it being
determined, like them
determining their own
fates right then and there.
I know where I'm going and
I know what I want to do.
Or I don't know and I
want you to save me.
And so that's what
we're faced with.
But it's such an honor
to do such every week.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: It's amazing.
I think it almost
takes you by surprise
how deep you get into it.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Because you're like
helping people.
And that's, man,
without the help,
I don't know where I
would be right now.
So it's my responsibility
to pay it forward.
And that's what being on
"The Voice" allows me to do.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
And Happiness Day.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: Yes.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
Thank you so much.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: I would
like to say thank you
to you, Lynn Hirschberg.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: My pleasure.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
And also to Google
for this amazing opportunity
to say hello and be
a part of this Happy Day.
And also the UN and Ban Ki-moon.
And I can't believe
he's even-- you know.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG: I
was pretty excited
when I heard it on the
radio this morning.
That's why we should
all listen to the radio.
Then we'll hear these things.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS: We should.
Radio is good to us.
Thank you again.
LYNN HIRSCHBERG:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]